comment faites-vous
pour travailler à la maquette de vre
visage
s Charles gonzalz interprète en robe le
rôle de tro femmes à la Maison de la
poésie à guillancour ainsi après avoir
joué Camille cludel mercredi soir c'est
au tour de thèse Davila de monter sur
scène ce jeudi pour le 3è jour de
représentation Charles gonzalz joue le
rôle de sarahe une dramaturge
britannique service on me tendant la
main la première Camille cludel dans la
première est ce soir ici mais que j'ai
joué partout depuis très longtemps c'est
le on pourrait dire ça le théâtre de la
de l'émotion
hein l'autre c'est thesa villa le
théâtre de le théâtre de la spiritualité
et la troisième S raquen c'est le
théâtre de de la cruauté cher monsieur F
Camille Claudel la trouve la lumière si
vous voulez elle la trouve à travers sa
sculpture Tha villa trouve sa lumière en
édifiant des des monastères au 16e
siècle sur tous les chemins d'Espagne
malgré sa maladie enfin c'est elle c'est
appel du Seigneur si vous voulez voilà
et saraken est la seule qui ne trouve
pas la
lumière concepteur réalisateur et
interprète Charles gonzalz met en
lumière ses femmes pendant 1h17 précise
pour tous ceux qui ont manqué les
représentations Charles gonzalz
incarnera ses trois personnages à la
suite samedi 19 janvier à 19h et des
mauvais